vamos ahora a demostrar el teorema de la
divergencia que nos dice que el flujo el
flujo a través de una superficie es de
algún campo vectorial que vamos a
llamarle efe efecom
con flechita porque es un campo
vectorial este flujo que lo podemos
expresar como la integral doble a lo
largo de esta superficie de efe punto n
de s va a ser igual va a ser igual a la
entre la integral triple la integral
triple es decir sobre una región sobre
un sólido digamos rellenito con volumen
de la divergencia de nuestro campo
vectorial
efe que multiplica por supuesto una
diferencial de volumen y esto ya lo
hemos estado revisando en otros vídeos
ahora lo que vamos a hacer es la
demostración de esta igualdad y lo que
vamos a tener que tomar al inicio son
algunas hipótesis vamos a tomar que r es
una región simple y sólida
simple
y sólida qué significa esto esto en
realidad no nos dice otra cosa más que
la región es de tipo 1 que también es de
tipo 2 y que también es de tipo 3 es
decir que esta región r va a ser de
todos los tipos que ya vimos en otros
vídeos ok ya hemos hecho entonces la
intuición de este teorema ahora vamos a
demostrarlo y vamos a empezar
partiendo de escribir quién es nuestro
campo vectorial es decir si yo tengo efe
mi campo vectorial esto yo lo puedo
escribir como una función p que depende
de x jay-z pero ahorita lo voy a omitir
que multiplica nuestro vector y más q
veces que también es una función que
depende de x jay-z que multiplica jota
más otra función r que multiplica al
vector unitario acá ok entonces si este
es nuestro campo vectorial quién es
efe punto si hacemos el producto punto
con nuestro vector normal unitario y
entonces como realmente efe es una suma
y estamos multiplicando con producto
punto pues es distribuir el producto
punto entonces aquí vamos a poder
expresar lo como p y vamos a hacer el
producto punto de y con n entonces
tenemos y punto n
y punto n más ahora nos vamos con el
segundo término que va a ser q jota que
multiplica a n entonces va a ser q que
multiplica jota punto n
vamos bien y finalmente el mismo
argumento vamos a tener a er que
multiplica acá punto n podemos pensar
que cada uno de estos términos que están
entre paréntesis es decir este este y
este en realidad esta es la magnitud de
la componente del vector normal unitario
n a lo largo de nuestro de nuestra
dirección x éste representaría esa
magnitud pero a lo largo de la dirección
y está a lo largo de la dirección z
entonces ya que tenemos esto podemos
simplificar o más bien podemos sustituir
en esta parte de amarillo como lo vamos
a hacer bueno esto recordemos por si por
si a lo mejor tienen alguna otra
anotación en alguno de sus libros que
también se puede escribir como la
integral sobre la superficie de f punto
de ese no es otra cosa más que lo que
tenemos acá arriba la integral doble
sobre la superficie
punto n df
de ese y que si sustituimos esto de aquí
esto simplemente va a ser la integral
doble sobre la superficie de esto que
tenemos aquí déjenme incluso
seleccionarlo y pegarlo
a seleccionar esto
y pegamos y simplemente lo ponemos aquí
ok entonces esto es lo que vamos a
tratar de simplificar o vamos a tratar
de manipular para llegar a la misma
expresión que tenemos del lado derecho
aquí por supuesto me faltó nada más
multiplicar por nuestra diferencial de
superficie ok entonces solo voy a
terminar con un detallito de este lado
de este lado izquierdo y es que esta
integral como es la integral de una suma
podemos escribir la suma de las
integrales entonces esto va a ser igual
va a ser igual a la integral de
superficie de p por i punto en ellas lo
voy a dejar del mismo color de ese más
ahora la integral de superficie de q por
jota punto n
más la integral de superficie de r por
cada punto n
esto es una de las partes que tenemos
ahora vámonos del lado derecho porque
ahora tenemos del lado derecho la
integral triple sobre la región r de la
divergencia del campo vectorial está
allí bueno quien es la divergencia de
nuestro campo vectorial vamos a
escribirlo aquí la divergencia de un
campo vectorial efe que tiene como
componentes a p q y r pues es
simplemente la suma de las derivadas
parciales en este caso sería la suma de
pp de la derivada de p respecto de x más
la derivada de q respecto de ye más la
derivada de r respecto d
ok esto es la divergencia entonces esto
de aquí lo podemos simplemente sustituir
por px mas q ya más receta ok todo esto
por la diferencial debe esto esto ahora
lo podemos también tenemos una integral
triple de una suma de tres funciones por
lo tanto podemos hacer la integral
podemos hacer las las 3 integrales de
cada una de éstas vamos a bajar un
poquito
entonces vamos a tener que es del lado
derecho de integral triple sobre nuestra
región r de px de b este es el primer el
primero de los sumandos aquí este y así
hacemos con él con el resto vamos a
tener más la integral triple sobre
nuestra región r de cuya de más la
integral triple ok de gm déjenme de gm
cambiar esto del lugar porque lo que
quiero es mostrarles realmente a dónde
va la demostración de este teorema
a nuestro color verde entonces aquí voy
a poner la integral triple sobre r dp x
de más la integral triple sobre r de
cuya debe más la integral triple sobre r
de receta bebé ok entonces hemos ya ha
reformulado el teorema de la divergencia
porque esto es lo que está del lado
izquierdo y esto es lo que está del lado
derecho de este teorema entonces
realmente lo que queremos es ver que
estas dos cosas son iguales y para
demostrarlo vamos a ver que los
siguientes términos son iguales es decir
lo que voy a hacer es demostrar que
estos que estoy en marcando son iguales
que también estos que voy a enmarcar
de aquí
estos de aquí estos segundos suman dos
son iguales y finalmente voy a demostrar
que estos últimos son iguales entonces
como son iguales entre entre sí vamos a
tener que la suma de estos va a ser
igual a la suma de estos otros en
particular vamos a concentrarnos en
estos últimos de acá en este que marque
con azul para hacer la prueba vamos a
demostrar que estos dos términos son
iguales son equivalentes basándonos en
el hecho de que la región es de tipo 1
de hecho supusimos que es de tipo 1 2 y
3 pero vamos a usar que es de tipo 1
para demostrar que estas dos cosas son
equivalentes y usando los mismos
argumentos utilizando que es una región
de tipo 2 y que es de tipo 3 se puede
demostrar que estos respectivos sumandos
son iguales